et en cette période de crise c'est vrai
que c'est difficile d'offrir une fête de
rêve à sa chérie sans se ruiner pour
vous aider mokhtar le cupidon des rings
vous propose des tuto pour la faire
rêver pour pas cher premier conseil de
ce soir lui faire un beau poème d'amour
pas cher regard des grandes feuilles tu
prends un feutre
vim
j'étais très un poème pour faire rêver
votre chéri pour pas cher leçon numéro 2
lui offrir une belle bague de
fiançailles c'est important je prends un
écrou tu prends un but de nuggets bible
veux tu m'épouser
cette fois ci comment offrir un beau
voyage de rêve à votre dulcinée
on pense que c'est cher pas tant que ça
à regarder tu prends un billet train
pour vesoul t'écris venise dessus bin
fêtais vallée chéri